Good morning, John!
Okay, say that you had to put a dollar amount on the value of a human life.
What would that dollar amount be?
The easy answer is that you can't do that.
It's immoral,  it's inconceivable, it's incalculable; the value of a human life!
But, you know we do it. The government of the United States says the minimum amount you can sell an hour of your life for is $7.80.
And the average wages of a person over their entire lives,
that's about two million dollars.
So that's kind of the value of a human life.
But no, it's not, that's the value of their economic input,
wages are paid per hour, but they're just a surrogate for, you know,
value created, for stuff made.
So let's try another angle,
Raw materials,
really raw materials, raw organs is what I'm talking about.
Uncooked, sold on the black market,
if i sold everything from my eyeballs to my forearms,
I could rake in about $500,000
Not bad, I wouldn't have much fun with it,
'cause of how I wouldn't have eyeballs or forearms,
but interestingly, $500,000 is also the number that the United States government
pays to the family of a fallen soldier.
But by other measures, this is very low.
Unlike working, advertising pays you for doing nothing
just for the presence your eyeballs in front of a screen.
The average cost of serving a thirty second television advertisement to a thousand people is about $24.
Math math math! That's $2.88 per hour multiplied by the number of hours in your life,
if you sold all of them this way, that would be, again, about two million dollars.
So, if we only sold the waking hours, because advertisers do not have the ability to advertise to us in our sleep,
that would only be about 1.3 million dollars.
Online video advertisements on the other hand, can go for less than a tenth of that,
so there's other reasons besides the fact that I'm annoyed by them that we avoid pre-rolls,
we just think they undervalue this community's time!
Why is you time, watching this video, worth a tenth of the time of a person watching a tv show?
I don't know! I think that's dumb!
But none of this is how economists actually calculate the worth of a human life, or of human time.
Basically, they do it one or two ways.
The first is to calculate the amount of money,
that a someone has to be paid extra, to do a job that has a certain risk of death.
So if there's a job and it's dangerous, like lumberjack or something,
and there's a one in one thousand chance that you're gonna die doing this job,
and you say ''I have to be paid ten thousand dollars more to do that job!'' then you have just valued your life.
You have made the decision that your life is worth ten million dollars.
Statistically.
Using this measure, various departments within the U.S. government put a value on a human life of about six to nine million dollars.
The second way is to calculate not how much you would need to get paid to risk your life,
but how much you would actually pay to save your life.
On the high end, this comes in at around a $130,000 for one year of high quality, non-painful life.
So if you'd extent someone's life by ten years and those will all be high quality, non-painful years,
that's worth about 1.3 million dollars.
And for 78 years of high quality life that comes out to a remarkably similar number,
ten million dollars!
And there ends the fact-y portion of the video, now we're onto the opinion-y.
It might initially seem crass or inhuman to say that there is an economic value of a human life,
and that instead you should just say
''We should do whatever we can to prevent death in every situation!''
but neh... To me that represents a kind of blindness to the inevitability of death.
Death has been good enough for everyone who has ever lived... So far.
It's not the moment of death where all the value get's created or lost,
to me, the value is in enabling the life, all of the finite moments that we have on this planet together.
It's not about preventing the death.
Which is gonna happen anyway.
John, this was supposed to be kind of a silly video and it ended up being a little bit heavy...
Sorry about that.
You were fantastic on the Late Late Show, and we shall continue our discussion
of how to make online video strong and awesome as the years progress soon!
I'll see you on Tuesday.